ich bin auf dem weg zu hugh grant hier
im zürcher luxushotel ballack und
eigentlich wollte ich ja teetrinken mit
ihm aber sein management hat uns gerade
mal vier minuten zugestanden
ja so ist das mit dem berühmtheiten
konzentriere ich mich lieber auf das
wesentliche schön sie zu sehen
unser thema ist die prominenz und wie
menschen damit umgehen also sie sind
prominent wie gehen sie denn damit um
im großen und ganzen überwiegen die
vorteile
aber ich träume immer davon einen
schalter für die prominenz zu haben
wenn ich zum beispiel tickets für ein
fußballspiel will dann würde ich gerne
den prominenz schalter drücken und ihn
wieder ausschalten wenn ich in ruhe im
pub eins trinken
die romantische komödie vier hochzeiten
und ein todesfall macht den damals 34
jährigen schauspieler weltberühmt
ab da ist er abonniert auf den
britischen underdog mit hang zur
leichten melancholie
ich glaube ich habe eine ente getötet
nick hornbys roman wird mit kran zum
kino kassenschlager
dort tauchte als eingefleischter single
in die welt des zwölfjährigen marke sei
nicht ganz ohne verluste sie sind ein
berühmter schauspieler sie ist eine
ikone war es einfach mit einer so
berühmten kollegin zu spielen wie war
die zusammenarbeit
man fühlt sich nie sicher auch merritt
street nicht auch sie ist nervös am
ersten drehtag und das obwohl sie eine
frau ist mit 19 oscar nominationen
unglaublich ich habe das irgendwie
gespürt was nicht wie war das für mich
wie heißt so ganz angenehm da war ich
weniger nervös
meryl streep neben grand die reiche
erbin florence foster jenkins
sie will es um jeden preis auf die große
opernbühne scharfer fehlendes talent für
sie kein hindernis
sie lieben es zu tanzen ich glaube in
jedem ihrer filme gibt es eine tanzszene
eine ihrer bedingungen wenn sie zu einem
film jahr sagen er hätte ich werde das
du lieber tanzen eine neue freude
ja ich denke schon je älter ich werde
desto weniger macht es mir auswendig
dabei wie ein idiot auch sehr
ich denke früher als die leute noch die
traditionellen tänze beherrschten hat
das tanzen auch mehr spaß gemacht als
ich in london aufgewachsen bin sind wir
mit der familie jeden sommer nach
schottland gefahren zu unseren
verwandten
wir haben die traditionellen
schottischen volkstänzen und mein bruder
ich sagte immer rat muss das sein
aber ich muss zugeben es hat wirklich
spaß gemacht
also ist es beim tanzen wie mit der
prominenz je älter man wird desto
einfacher werde jahre vielleicht schon
vielen dank